dieses hat sich ja passt hat mein Leben
verändert ich zeige dir wie man sie
macht zuallererst braten wir unsere
salsica an dafür befreien wir sie aus
der Wursthaut und braten Sie in einer
Pfanne an natürlich ohne hier was zu
verschwenden nee ordentlich hoch mit der
Hitze bisschen zerkleinern und einfach
schön anbraten von allen Seiten unser
Nudelwasser kocht das Salzen wir und
geben unsere Nudeln hinein die wir drei
vier Minuten zu kurz kochen das hier ist
der teacher pikante für eine schöne
scharfe Pasta wenn die Zeit sieht schon
angebraten ist gebe ich Zwiebel dazu
findest du die ein bisschen mit an
einfachen italienischer Traum und so
eine leichte Pasta jetzt mal ein
bisschen Knoblauch dran haut euch mal an
wie schön das hier geworden ist und
jetzt ist der perfekte Zeitpunkt und mit
ein bisschen Weißwein abzulöschen
also ich gebe jetzt für Geschmack noch
ein zwei San marsano Tomaten dazu und
ein bisschen Sauce zack so die
zerkleiner ich einfach und kocht die
noch ein bisschen ein und jetzt geben
wir unsere Nudeln bisschen unterkocht in
unsere Soße wir kochen die Nudeln jetzt
quasi in ihrer Soße fertig so verbindet
sich das Ganze sieht schon super aus und
servieren